c'est un sport venu tout droit des pays
nordiques pas besoin de beaucoup de
matériel pour le pratiquer juste des
bâtons la marche nordique allons la
découvrir bonjour armen beaux jours mais
la nuit quels sont les bienfaits de ce
sport et bien c'est une marche dynamique
qui se pratique dans la nature le plus
souvent dans les parcs et forêts
environnantes ici aversenq qui a besoin
d'un grand niveau s'est adapté à tout le
monde s'est adapté à tout le monde
faut être en forme il ya quelques
petites contradictions
si on a des problèmes de tendinite mais
sinon c'est ouvert à tout le monde mais
bon on peut le découvrir
bien sûr j'imagine on voit les
participants on commence par un
échauffement c'est ça bien sûr alors
c'est parti
[Musique]
ça réchauffe et savait veille
c'est plus en fait très agréable parce
que on sent que tout se réchauffent de
capes et j'attends de voir la marche
un échauffement nécessaire de tout le
corps la marche nordique sollicite
jusqu'à 90% de nos muscles
ar mais nous voilà bien les chauffer on
va partir sur la marche mais on a des
bâtons j'imagine qu'il manière spéciale
de s'en servir
oui tout à fait le bâton ce nous sert à
nous qu il fait donc pour ça c'est
important de lancer son bras vers
l'avant le braille plutôt temps du
passage du horn et ensuite on va planter
de bâton derrière et on a toujours un
bras et une jambe opposée et le bâton se
plante derrière l'a fait d'accord
[Musique]
sport très conviviale la marche nordique
se pratique idéalement en groupe grâce
au bâton en carbone un marcheur peut
atteindre 6 km heure très vite la marche
devient naturel alors si vous aussi vous
voulez essayer une séance d'initiation
est prévue le dimanche est très attendu
à 10h30 et ça commence dès l'âge de 16
ou 17 ans
[Musique]